joining me now back here on the rich
eisen show via zoom is a friend and a
friend of the program
pleased to call him both he is nominated
for his role
in black monday and uh the ten time
emmy award nominee don cheadle here on
the rich eisen show how are you sir good
to see you rich i'm very good how are
you
i am doing well uh it does look like you
just came off of
uh hitting 18. is that uh is that how i
it does it looks like you got that
working well look i'm in hawaii
the only clothes that i have in hawaii
are hawaiian clothes
and for me that means golf clothes
that's right
so it was either this very muted you
know toned down
or some really garish flower full okay
okay i just made it i made an executive
decision it went with the muted tones i
think that's a
solid executive decision how is the don
cheadle golf game
walk me through what what what we have
here don well
right now uh it's mostly been me hitting
balls from my backyard
into the driving range because i'm 14
day quarantined here
uh on the big island in cohen right
uh-huh
good and appropriate we got to make sure
we have a handle on this thing
yes crazy in hawaii but uh
uh my handicap is i think i'm a seven
right now so
i could get it down but then i can't win
any money
in the nassau so i'll just stay okay
who's the best stick
the athlete that you've ever been in a
foursome with or you've played with
who's the best
jason gore no kidding why walk me
through
well jason gore shot 59 you know no i'm
i'm not talking about i'm sorry the zoom
kind of hit me right there i'm not
not a player like another athlete
who's not an actual player
not somebody who shot a 59 yeah
an actual an athlete who's not actually
a player
quarterback pitcher anybody that's
tricky i mean you know aaron rodgers is
pretty good
i think uh he he maybe fudged his
uh handicap in the bmw tournament we're
not going to get into that
wow are you saying the best stick in his
bag is his pencil his eraser is that
what you're saying
he pencil whipped anybody i'm not going
to say he went in as a 14 and he's
really like a six
i'm not gonna i'm not saying that okay
you're not
let's restrain okay you're not saying
that okay
um but uh let me another actor who's
really good oliver hudson he's a stick
no kidding okay
he's probably a plus one or two now come
on i could not imagine
ever waking up and saying i'm gonna play
golf today and i'm going to give
strokes to the group i know right now
like here's what i will do you know i'm
just being i'm just feeling so
magnanimous i'm going to give strokes to
this golf course that's going to try and
beat me i just can't imagine that
and then when you play with pros they're
that are clearly you know pluses
and they play scratch i don't understand
that that is so not cool
that is not cool all right so you're set
seven's a pretty good night is that the
is that your best ever or were you i got
it down to a five once
when i was spending a ton of time out
here
and just playing and practicing all the
time but
if it gets too low it means don's not
working so
we don't if you see as i'm a scratch
golfer you won't be doing these with me
anymore
i don't know maybe
that is true that is true that means you
stick to your day job or your night job
as opposed to your
your golf game so what's your favorite
course you've ever played
which one have you been on probably
that's amazing right when you're
standing there on 18
oh my gosh there's nothing like that
spot there really isn't it's
it's hard to beat uh good weather bad
weather i mean it can be brutal in bad
weather as we know but
right when it's pretty out there there's
just there's no i mean cyprus is also
of course an amazing golf course it'd be
cyprus or pebble but it makes sense
they're both in that corner of the woods
i
what i'm looking forward to and look
great on tv when they just played it
it's abandoned i've never been abandoned
that's right oh yeah
okay you know and and it's you know it
has been amazing
to see golf obviously in this quarantine
in this world this crazy world that
we're living in right now but it has
been amazing to see
these players out there and it kind of
all started
in a way of you know that that brady
manning phil tiger that that was that
was really at the very beginning of back
in may i guess not very beginning
but i i thought it was pretty cruel that
people were ripping on brady
you know for not having you know like he
wasn't
plus one or plus two you know i mean
giving
beautiful i thought it was great i
actually
i actually loved that they were ripping
on him why is that
they could have ripped on him a little
more is that is that because of who you
root for
in the nfl no obviously obviously
well you want to fill people in uh for
who may not know i mean
so look i have some afc sort of
issues mental issues you know i have a
schism as
it were because i was born in kansas
city missouri i grew up there
you know lived there for many years and
then moved to denver colorado
so when the broncos play the chiefs yes
yeah root for the chiefs okay
but actually if anybody is playing
against
you know new england
i don't care who it is i don't so now i
don't know what to do with the whole
tampa bay thing i'm not you know
i'm not sure where to go now i feel kind
of lost without a
an enemy without without your north star
from new england for you to start
rooting against them i know
exactly can i hate them both can i hate
him
sure you know well i mean there are pete
there are
fans of brady who feel that they have an
afc team and now an nfc team so you
could go the exact reverse
you guys say that you have an afc team
you dislike and now an nfc team that you
dislike
it's i i prefer that i prefer the hater
raid
you could go in that direction don i
mean uh let them come for you
what was that like to see the chiefs win
a super bowl then for you
um unbelievable it actually i was so
uh i actually left i was actually here
when that happened
and i i when it wasn't looking good
i just i walked away and i just went and
by myself there was nobody on the golf
course of course because everybody's
watching the super bowl
right i just went and played a few holes
and kept my phone off so i was like if
they're going to lose
i don't want to know it's not life yeah
i was like i don't want to watch him
lose
and if they win i'm taping it i'll just
plug my ears and get home and watch it
but i can't watch them lose every
playoff game was like why are you guys
doing this
every playoff game you have to be down
20 down 15 down 25 why are you doing
that
just win it was so hard to watch then
the actual super bowl itself
looked pretty bleak until what i'm
saying i'm out there playing
i'm like i'm just going to go hit balls
because i can't deal with it it's like
you're not going to watch i'm like no
i'm not going gonna watch
right text me i'm just gonna go hit
balls don cheadle here on the rich eisen
show let's talk about black monday
um you've been in so many special
projects
television shows and movies where is
this one ranked for you
done oh well i love this one i'm having
a great time on the show
we have a great cast we have
you know great people in front of and
behind the camera
um this one was fun from the beginning
you know
when seth and evan came on they produced
and seth and evan directed it seth
uh came on with with david and
and jordan who are the writers and the
show creators and
this was just something that there's one
of those things where you read it and it
just makes you laugh
from beginning to end i couldn't
anticipate it i didn't know what was
going to happen
it was like a weird whodunit in a half
hour comedy that i'd never seen
that kind of you know mix of genres so
it was just really exciting from the
beginning david evans called me it's so
funny because david
nevins had a showtime called me he said
i have this show
i'm not sure that you're right for it i
said
okay he's like all right well what a
cell talking to you
right what a cell job and did he not see
house of lies for for five seasons on
his own
uh yeah he watched it a lot but he's
like i don't know if this one's good for
you i don't know
so we talked about other stuff and then
i didn't talk to him for a week and he
called me back and he said you know what
i've been thinking about it now i
actually think
i only see you in it so why don't we get
together with everybody and see if we
can make it work which was great and we
did and then we put the show together
and
like i said i'm having a great time on
well i know you know obviously both of
those shows on showtime uh
in its own right in its own way um even
though obviously we're talking about
different time periods we're kind of
of the time that we're we're living in a
little bit right now you know
like to kind of um i'm wondering
how you view um your previous
work in house of lies and how that might
have you know about what to believe and
what to see and how
and how and how things are are shaped
for
people's consumption um if you thought
maybe
you might have been a little ahead of
the times a little bit with that show
well it is
it is a show that interesting enough i
think people are finding
now that they didn't see it originally
um and another great show with the great
cast and a lot of fun
in in a very different way i think how i
think you know house of lies was
was much more andromedy and i think that
that this one is just a straight-up
sitcom on you know on cable which is
rare to see
these rapid fire jokes the constant you
know
self sort of referential jokes that we
make and and with the lens of
you know looking back at the looking at
this time through the lens of the 80s
right which is really a cool
juxtaposition um
they're very different shows in that
regard but yeah i i hope this is
something that people watch
now they don't have to wait you know you
can you can check it out it's on
it's on now so watch it watch it later
too but watch it now
well actually i think the phrase is
anytime right that's the showtime
anytime
um just i just i don't want to get you
in trouble with you know
nevins or anybody like that showtime
anytime is another way that you can
watch
uh black monday with don cheadle here on
the rich eisen show did you
um did you enjoy the password
that i had you type in for this zoom did
you enjoy that
uh i didn't actually have to type it in
but i did
i did clock it and i was very impressed
what was the password for you to enter
this this zoom
i did clock that and i was very
impressed
and a little touched actually that you
would think of me
when when you did yeah i i kind of like
to
i kind of like to just you know throw a
little bit uh
throw something out there that might not
be expected
um yeah all right richard yes
when you first picked up the script of
boogie nights and reddit
what what in the world did you think don
uh
why are you guys handing me a 165 page
script
that's a good start that's a good start
massive
and uh really gave us an insight into
paul's mind paul thomas anderson who
wrote and directed it
um because it was really very technical
it had every camera move that he wanted
to do and it had you know
speeds that he was going to ramp the
camera to and and
it was just a i hadn't you know snap
zooms things that you
aren't used to i hadn't been used to it
until that point
reading in scripts so it was reading
sort of the shooting script
the manual as well as trying to read the
actual words
and you know i uh i was introduced to
paul by
um carl franklin who directed devil in
the blue dress
and he said i met this dude and he i
think he's going to be great he's a
young guy he's super cocky he's really
smart
um but i think he's gonna be great and i
think you should meet him
and he's got this movie idea and i said
what's the movie i did goes well it's
boogie nights and it's it's about the
porn industry and i said oh
like my both of my parents are alive so
i i won't be doing
any of that he said no just meet him
just meet him just meet him
so we went to um what's the diner that
was on san vicente i think they closed
it but that big
you know anyway so we met and
he was as as promised really cocky
super confident very smart uh
and just said this if you don't say yes
to this movie you're gonna be sorry
so you should just agree to do it come
on
that's a quote i mean this is the same
dude that called me after he did punch
drunk love
and you know i i i call him i said so
how's the movie he goes
it's an instant classic wow
because they said i couldn't do it they
said i couldn't do a movie in 90 minutes
well i did it and it's an instant
classic
i was like you're pretty confident
aren't you paul he goes you're damn
right
and the movie's great i love i love
paul's confidence and he obviously is
an amazing director as evidenced by his
you know
his his track record well boogie nights
for me is a remote drop movie it does
not
matter what i'm doing or where i'm
picking it up
i have to watch it to its conclusion you
know like
that's what but do you have one of those
where you're obviously you're in
quarantine right now
where you consider like whether it's
something you've done or anything else
that you're
those i would never no those no okay
remote drop movie for
for you don't you know what is that
again
matrix no kidding yeah why is that
why i don't know why i just think that
it's
it's one of those movies that is it was
so
different you know and and
the idea the concept of it was so
interesting
and just the everything about it it's
just the way it was shot
how it looks uh the acting i just
thought it was a great movie and it's
one of those things where if i catch it
wherever it is in the movie i'm usually
going to sit down and watch it and
godfather of course
yes of course and godfather too i guess
that's a godfather too
and actually malcolm x okay
i haven't seen that one in a while i
haven't seen that but that's obviously
one of the
greatest performances you can see and
the story
and i love al pacino but that denzel
lost that year to al pacino that's the
year i was kind of like i don't know
about you oscars
that's right oh i hear you um so um one
last one for you
um so uh we all know carl rainer
recently passed away
and i don't know how many scenes you did
with him in the oceans films where you
were in the same scenes
but i'm wondering if you've got any good
stories of carl from the
the scene from the set of these oceans
films at all
or any any memories that you might want
to pass along of uh carl rauner
well you know carl was obviously the
consummate professional
and and and he was our you know
grandfather
on the set and really
what was great is that even with all of
his experience and clearly all of his
years
he was really you know
deferential to everyone and just wanted
to be a part of the team
and wasn't in any way shape or form
trying to you know lord his
his you know extensive comedy acumen
over us everybody was you know a part of
the team and part of the crew we just
all felt like you know
uh people who had known each other for a
long long time so i think that's just a
testament to his personal always kind
always generous
just a good dude you know well those
move those films are just
some great ones as well don you've been
in so many great films tv shows again as
i said i guess it brings us full circle
here
uh everyone can watch seasons one and
two of black monday available on
showtime
anytime in showtime now uh as well and
uh
good good luck good luck in winning the
emmy sir you uh you deserve it
thank you appreciate it rich good to see
you now you got it hope you get out of
quarantine and hit him straight
when you can i'm gonna do my best it's
don cheadle right here on the rich eisen
show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here